ring the bell of honor for stone cold oh
my god don't do it here is the telephone
are all my gosh Stone Cold Steve I'm
sorry you have to deal with the Bell
welcome to the show that has to be the
most goddamn irritating thing you could
hear walking into a studio is a cowbell
announcing your entrance honored guests
I wouldn't feel I mean to walk into a
radio studio and the cow bell is ringing
Mitchell especially designed Bell Ivana
for Steve explain to me this brillo pad
that is attached to you thank you what
are the wide wide world of sports is it
go it old here Steve you know how
important it is for men to have
masculinity about them and you know that
something I struggle with for a long
time no no not you
[Music]
and so I grew this beard because I can
grow beard yeah and that's one of the
few masculine things that I can pull off
you know it is your hair kind of keeps
migrating sound that's right this talk
to my wife and I was like you know
Sphinx is gonna do some TV stuff so I'm
like I'm trimming up my nose hairs I've
got hairs in my ears I'm like when all
this stuff started migrating south now
some of my back in my ears and my nose
and what the hell happened what went
wrong it's a man gestation it's a
paradigm shift as far as the hair
follicles are concerned
yeah probably used no it didn't bother
me because it was the best thing that
ever happened to me because you know
that when when you got back in and
pro-wrestling back in the day you had to
have long hair because that's kind of
like the thing to do but when I shaved
off my head my hair my head it all
worked out there's a happy ending here
yeah but I you have a good head like my
head is so big and my body is so slight
a frame yeah I got nowhere to go man no
no no that don't be so negative don't be
so hard on yourself but he's right he is
right
correct he doesn't miss shapen head and
an awful little body now does that I
mean this normally hair being added to
the back wouldn't bother you but when
you're a pro wrestler and you're walking
around in little trunks all day now
you've got all this body hair that you
got to shave all the time is that right
well since I'm kind of retired it'll be
like I'll be walking around the house
without my shirt on and my wife will
look at my back yeah the hair on my back
it'll get about three inches long it's
just it's kind of a thing where we do it
like once a quarter yeah I comes back do
each when it comes back and then one
time she talked me into going to getting
waxed and then it lays back and puts
that stuff I'm just a Rip's here I'll
you know out of your back I said I'm
hurt yeah yeah I'm like man what a
toughest human being should ever walk
gods greener are just thinking that but
some ladies out there pulled ahead can
you imagine getting your bag waxed where
you want to do it for the TV show what
if you've met somebody that you were
like okay you know we got this TV show
we're doing interviews but we're going
on adventures we've done everything
there is to do it's time to get a nice
Brazilian wax
it's parently very painful very painful
especially and I'm done
keep it nice and trim I don't want to
see it gray I'm getting more gray hair
so I keep this short and it's just it's
depressing neck to toe you're bald
pretty much Wow yeah that's how you do
that once a week yeah I can't I let it
go I can see how much gray is coming in
yeah I don't need to know it like I know
it but I don't need to see it yeah yeah
same here
yeah you're like with the goatee when he
gets you a couple more gray hairs
everyday you do anything with it do you
dye it
man it is what it is yeah do you do you
keep your head like shaved like tv-ready
shaved when you're not doing TV or if
you're out on the ranch is there some
growth coming oh man there's some growth
and I got that horseshoe South Texas
that's what I tell my wife that's what
kind of grow my stuff and like you would
yeah I wouldn't have enough time it'd be
over two months man I see but I'd get a
pretty good little you know you turn to
a man again right and then I would keep
this with just my my peanut clipper and
so because when that kind of starts
growing in but you know we got the
horseshoe yeah that's that I would keep
that at a certain length but I'd let
this go thank you towards the end of
deer season if two months of solid
growth I I really started feeling a lot
more manly that's why I grew this you
feel more man of course then I go back
to LA and do stuff so I gotta shave it
off right but now that I've been doing
so much TV like I'll shave about every
other day just so I can keep everything
nice and tight because when you start
letting all this get out of control it's
easy to keep manicured and looking good
if you stay on top of it so that's what
the conditioner when you shoot you want
to look the same every day you can't
look different and have a long hair one
day and sure when you went back to raw a
couple weeks ago did they have the beard
guys there have you seen that the WWE's
got beard guys and at the shows now yeah
got a beard there's beard trimmers at
every show now like two or three guys
Sam thought he was some guy took Sam
into his car do you work for them in the
yeah there are a lot of guys on the show
Rock and these new beards right it's
kind of like the end thing to do
laughing what the long hair back in the
day these days is all about a big-ass
beard right now do you feel pressure
especially when you're doing TV that you
got to keep the goatee cuz you you just
have to look like stone cold you figured
out your look you got to keep the look
it's not about looking like stone cold I
just you know when you don't have any
hair anymore and you've been used to
seeing me with a goatee for so long I
remember when I shaved the mustache off
many years ago just to do like a
low-budget movie you know and I just had
this and I
appeared to promote the Expendables and
all of a sudden all I had was just this
chin piece about the stache and
everybody's like who is this freak yeah
you don't look the same we don't want
him we think oh this is the best look
for me and although I've been married
and stuff like that for you know 15
years you know I'm not trying to you
know be an international it's time to be
a sex symbol I have a question about
hunting too cuz you're in the woods all
day
have you gotten ticks that freaks me out
Lyme disease scares me Lyme disease okay
I gotta pull him off my dog yeah yeah
that's different and you can also bust
out a cigarette lighter there's all
kinds of territories would get into but
we have maybe maybe not but yeah man to
your point man one time me and my
brother went out and you got this deer
so I figured oh man you know I'm big
macho dude you know better than Jim so
I'll just pick damn thing up throw it on
my shoulders I carried that thanks for
about 300 yards put it in the trunk of a
Camaro it's way back in the day and man
I just had ticks all over me because you
don't realize how many ticks I'm like
yeah I'm like oh nice things I got about
a flea collar
cuz flea collars also know you've really
hit out there and shot the deer while I
was carrying them on my shoulder right
there easy kill they see me laying
everything deer hey we got the bonus
plan that's that messes you up and you
don't even know you have it so I avoid
the woods but hunters I'm like how these
guys might get them all the time man you
see when you take a shower just check
your body and if you see one feel one
whatever get that sumbitch off of you
yeah now you just pull it or do you have
your own mat for your burner to put
vaseline I think yeah you pull it you
know get tweezers make sure you get that
little prongs out there oh there's a how
did we come here to talk about a show
and end up talking about ticks it's
important well it's important I want to
promote the show Sam didn't want to but
I want to ask
ticks me off about this show
some of your guests know the guests are
I want to deceive to say it work with me
here
man we had a Gabriel Iglesias on their
fluffy guy he was like when the hardest
to uh touring comedians out there right
now he's incredibly a road warrior
because like fit two weeks in the year
he's out forty six of them yes he's like
the boys and you've got this compound in
Long Beach and he built it he's such a
fan he built us like an exact replica of
how WWE would do something he's got his
18-wheeler with his March on there he's
got a yeah that goes out on tour he's
serious about it and you know is
crushing it so doing arenas and theater
that son of the [ __ ] makes a lot of
money give you is a hugely successful uh
fee is I ain't I interviewed him and we
obviously we got to talking about
wrestling and I you know asked him for
stories or whatever first story told me
is that one time I got to take a [ __ ] in
Stone Cold's house was like the first
time or second time he came over to the
show but the first time he came over you
know I was kind of like in one of those
fitness kicks depending on what I'm
trying to do I like to drink I'm trying
to get in shape for a show whether you
gotta take you know cut back on the
alcohol so at the time fluffy came over
I wasn't really drinking so he shows up
at 11:00 in the morning with a fifth of
Jack's some tequila patron silver and a
six-pack of beer something like Jesus
Christ are you kidding me I thought it's
kind of like a formality and fluffy
brings all that [ __ ] over you got to
start drinking it so help well we're
hammered he had to get his assistant or
whatever wants to drive him home and
messed up the rest of my day my wife my
wife was really impressed yeah we had a
really good time I got to hang out with
Becky Lynch the man and you know I've
known Becky for a long time but to spend
you know we film a show it's a half-hour
show but it takes all day to film and
we're doing different setups different
activities stuff did you know that would
come from my world or that would come
from someone else's world and we're
doing it together and I get a chance to
know to learn about them and what
what got them to be successful or what
drives em it's it's like like a talk
show where we're we're getting to know
each other and doing activities to help
facilitate the process what's something
you did that you would probably not have
done otherwise what was one of those
things done we did Brazilian wax
other than the Brazilian wax i i put an
apple on my head and let trace adkins
with with a bow and arrow shoot the
Apple off my head
really no but it's a junior and I'm a
huge car fan and race fan and sort of
hanging out with that guy and then we're
riding around his pickup truck and you
need to drive slow as molasses get him
out on a track I told Everett story and
and to find out why he ended up leaving
the business you know kind of enough of
the same reasons I left but you know
there's always kind of like you know
there's a little end point yeah
parallels and go to Cleveland and hang
out with Baker Mayfield and to get a
dose of what that guy is who's making me
feel Baker meg Baker Mayfield was a
Heisman Trophy winner and the first guy
taking an NFL Draft a season ago and
then came in for Cleveland completing a
rod Taylor goes down with an injury so
he comes in three or four games in the
season and throws 20 what was it 27
touchdowns he broke Peyton Manning and
Russell Wilson touchdown record and
didn't really start the entire season so
just a very accurate quarterback came
with some controversy he was never ever
planned a even coming out of Lake Travis
and he walked on at Texas Tech got an
injury walked on to oh you
Oklahoma and then got drafted number one
and won the Heisman so he's just this
guy who was never supposed to be the guy
but he is and he just has this era of
confidence he's very charismatic and
guys rally around him so I got a chance
to really meet and hang out with a lot
of people out here and you know Sam I've
been off the road for a long time yeah
so to get back on the road it was kind
of fun you liked it well yeah because I
always think when you travel as much as
we did you know you kind of turn into a
zombie and you're going through
everything and making your towns you're
going to the gym
you know you you trained do all your
stuff you show up at the building you
work your ass off and it's off to the
next gig and that's that's just life but
when you yeah I had to leave you know
after a Russell 1919 and I it took me
three years to turn back into a civilian
so I don't like travel anymore but to
travel for the show and go meet some of
the people that I've met and to go to
some of the towns which we used to sell
out every single time we went to it's
cool to go back to those places it's
probably also nice knowing there's an
end point here I'm filming X number of
episodes and then I'm back to life yeah
and you know to to get on Becky's grind
well and love these because fluffy was
on the grind hell he brought us to her
bus you know because we got a chance to
film that actually in LA so he brought
us to her bus down so he would just hang
there but yeah everybody's doing a thing
and for me to get back out on the road
or to do most of these in LA you know
and I can be back at the career boom
what do you what do you think you talked
about having Becky Lynch on what do you
think of the fact that like you know she
goes on this run that started about a
year ago and for the last year or so
every conversation about her is oh she's
the next Dunkel she's the next don't
call to your comparison to her comes up
more often and just about anything yeah
does I think it's because we both came
from Pro Wrestling right and because she
also gets a lot of comparisons to Conor
McGregor
yeah but she's Irish yep and he has to
but man I think she's done things
there's parallels surely but but I think
she's kind of won in her own you know
and she has been on a hot streak and to
come up with that with that gimmick and
I asked her on the show I said hey man
when you pitch this not I want to give
it away but you know I love that gimmick
the man oh yeah yeah premier I mean
she's a very talented woman wrestler and
very beautiful and she's the man right I
dig it right sounds like my life you
know what she's alpha yeah she takes
control of the situation she's very
articulate she's very eloquent and she's
very confident I got and I got a chance
to find out exactly how confident she
was you know spending 12 hours of a day
with her and doing different things and
she's just a very charismatic and just a
tremendous sense of humor and the bottom
line is she's very persistent
goal-oriented and she's just relentless
as far as her drive so her success does
not surprise me you've learned a lot of
things down like because you do shows
you doing you're always great on so it's
like you probably get a lot of things
that you don't want to do to just do
stuff that you think is gonna be fun man
iiiii when I first moved to LA many
years ago and this is three years after
you know I retired from the business it
took me a long time to come to grips
with that and then I finally said I had
no desire on being an actor but I said
hey man just based on your past you
might want to take your ass out to LA
and so I started doing some low-budget
stuff and then when I started getting a
chance to host with tuff enuf you know
we reincarnated it that's when I kind of
fell in love with you know the reality
aspect of television ended you know
redneck island and broken skull
challenge and some rocket scientists
pulled the plug on that that shows on TV
yeah and so they get approached with
this thing and it sounds like man this
is cool because I get a chance to be me
talk to people I've been done a podcast
for six years and that being said I had
a lot to learn because you know it's
kind of like it's a version of my
podcast but we're doing activities and
all of a sudden Sam you've been to my
house three sixteen games and I've got a
picture of you giving me sitting there
and please tell me it's not hanging up
of course it is I signed it was just you
and me in rooms you have to breathe -
cats yeah and so now sudden you've got
85 people and you're filming a bunch of
activities so there's a lot going on
there's a lot of moving pieces and a lot
of moving parts and there's a lot to
learn and just just as far as blocking
cameras this at or whatever so I'll turn
to you a question yeah I really just
want to do things that I'm interested in
and when they pitch this I said man that
sounds like a great idea and when you go
into that first season you know your
language parameters you said are you
okay I mean I mean really you have a
plan but you're throwing [ __ ] on the
wall okay what sticks oh that's kind of
sliding down but we like it it's kind of
like is this working progress that
you're tweaking and so hopefully you
know this first season goes well and
then we can apply as now as I look at
the cuts that they're putting together
based on what we did I say okay and get
the beats and
I kind of find I'm kind of finding
myself as that interviewer or that
person as compared to like you know when
you and I talked or whatever because on
a one-on-one thing and all these people
with different agendas different
information to cover there's a lot going
on so hopefully you know we found we
find our way we find our place people
find the channel and they tune in and
set their f and DVR when you go back to
a to a WWE arena its first time in years
when you did we're all reunion a couple
weeks ago I would imagine it's
impossible for you to get out of that
building without being pitched a hundred
ways to come back and do something
no nobody pitched anything really no no
and you know think about that but that
day was it was so fun man I was just
looking forward to it because it really
was they billed it as a like a family
reunion it was and like all the guys and
showed up and the flare called me as
soon as he got there and well when he
said hey man were down to borrow I was
waiting all day I was supposed to do a
podcast that day with a Booker T but me
and Booker T at our dates crossed up
uh-huh he didn't show up to the next day
so anyway I'm like waste
I've wasted a whole day and all of a
sudden flares down at the bar at 4:30
let me clarify he was down there hanging
at the bar right I went down and Flair
starts telling stories you know I have a
couple of cold ones mhm
so anyway but it was great to see all
the guys and girls and I remember going
up to the elevator to get my room
service and then come back down for one
more round
Tamara was gone and the door opens on
floor number five and there's Ron
Simmons and I told his story in that
promo as like we both saw each other and
Ron is like it's beast of a man right
and we head east these giddy smiles on
our face and we just hug for like 30
seconds it was the most manly hug and
he's like hugging the refrigerator so we
go back down and it was such a blast and
when I got out there you know for the
before that promo section it was really
weird because in that world I'm Stone
Cold Steve Austin
frame but toughest sob lace up a pair of
boots called mud holes for people to
walk them dry
well when I'm get too creative a go in
there and have a quick meeting with the
events hey man you can close the show
you know did you get a promo I said yeah
they gave me a couple of paragraphs with
some [ __ ] on it I said you know I get a
little sappy and then you know I talked
to a couple of guys I rented my
Pritchard he goes on you know
well it's live TV all you got to do is
go out there and you know don't don't as
long as it doesn't suck the old man to
be happy and I don't work out memory
anyway right and so and the thing about
it was there was a lot of moving parts
out there so I'm going out there to
thank the people thank my brothers and
sisters being on the road
it's very uncool like right and more
Steve Austin like because I do
appreciate all my brothers and sisters
so to go out there from that crowd when
I went out there and the roof broke the
roof blew off the place that's gonna ask
you when you because you go out right
and it's not just the roof blown off the
place but first Rick flair gets the
introduction then Hulk Hogan gets the
introduction then it's stone cold and I
mean you know no disrespect to you are
those two guys but your reaction Eclipse
to either their reactions are you
sitting there listening to that going
like holy [ __ ] this is it I'm number one
well now do you live and die by it
anybody tells you any different there's
no lying to you so man I was like god
dang and you're thankful for it because
I've been gone a long time yeah it was
very appreciative of it I go in there
hit some corners grab those beers and
then when I hit that first turnbuckle
and throw my arms up this this this ring
right here just flies off my hand into
the crowd and hits the barricade it's
laid there on the floor and I'm gonna
lie I'm gonna live TV with my hands up
in the air and I'm like there's my
effort and I went to the other one I
kept marking my ring well I've known of
those camera guys and all the cable guys
sound guys for 25 years they saw what
happened they picked up my ring because
I didn't want a fan to reach over and
grab my ring back forever yeah but it
was weird because when I when I watched
it back finally I had parted with flare
for two nights in a row and he was
nursing a Bud Light
cuz everybody say oh he's down Tamar
he's drink and he's not supposed to be
doing that he was nursing a Bud Light
where I was the one throwing back the
cocktails
so when I go out there my voice is
halfway blowed out partying Clair two
nights in a row and then talking with
all the WWE Superstars you know and to
see all the guys that I was on
with and hug them and talk about the old
times and then see someone new says hey
man come over here you might want to try
this
think about this you know you're trying
to pass lonesome information but it was
a blast just going there but no they
didn't pitch me anything
come on Simmons runs two restaurants no
wrestling fans hate your questions well
Ron Simmons is the first way is the
first WCW black heavyweight champion of
the world
you know was you know all-american
football players who time all-american
Florida yeah Florida State and I mean so
here's a highlight in college football
he's the legend oh yeah and he's legit
one of the toughest guys ever Ron
Simmons you'd come in here and just say
the ABCs and make it but even nobody and
everybody knows how tough the Steiner
Brothers work you know their shooters
are tough and they are a little bit out
there sweetheart
I mean they're great guys but nobody
nobody mess with Ron Simmons ever right
right you know you know and this is I
guess more for Jim who doesn't have the
encyclopedic wrestling knowledge that
some of us do but I don't know if Jim
knows everything that uh ol stone-cold
did in his heyday what comes to mind
when I think of like my favorite things
that stone cold did to mr. McMahon was
probably the episode where you had Vince
McMahon on national television pissing
himself quite literally you put a gun to
his head he pissed himself you pulled
the trigger and a little flag came out
that said bang 3:16 well Vince has piss
all over his pants was there anything
that was pitch to you to do in that era
where you were like this I we can't do
this I'm not doing this man that actual
incidence I was like man if I hold a gun
to his hand it's got a graphic yeah I
was thinking about one of the times when
me and Kane we're gonna have a first
blood match and he'd say and he said if
he's if he lost the match he's gonna set
himself on fire
and I'm thinking okay you know if I go
out there and endorse you so you know
people could be setting themselves on
fire
yeah then I thought people might be
taking this so many things a little too
literally here or seriously so along the
way you know there was a couple things
at work
so AGI I kind of thought yeah it could
be repercussions from this but you know
at the end of the day always said let's
go for it and you would think that I
would have said hey go but when they
said hey well you're gonna go bust in
the Pillman's house and you're gonna
break out his window with a baseball bat
and then Pillman's gonna pull a gun on
you and maybe shots are fired or maybe
they're not fired but and you know
they've gotten a lot of trouble for that
for good especially I mean that's the
best before wrestling even got edgy
that's the beginning of him and no pun
intended but it was like a shoot and
people are like oh you cross line and
it's like when you're wrestling when you
cross you know a line because of what
you are and I was kind of like being
construed as being so real that's why we
cross the line right but I love that
angle yeah I thought it was so great
because it felt real like all of a
sudden you're invested in this thing I
have a question too about dukers hotdogs
is a big fan and you're standing there
you have any question you want to ask
him to that mic oh yeah and he came in
early for you yeah we on the spot right
now huge fan nice to meet you you don't
answer the question no I'll just listen
to you guys that's fine all right I know
I believe from the west coast to the
east coast I'm sitting here and hot dog
ain't got a question for me Steve you
know you talk about the young guys in
wrestling there you go you got to make
the most of your moments right now they
give you this they give you TV time they
give you what it is but you get out
there and you make the most of your
moments we just gave hotdog what's known
in the business as an opportunity as a
fan any blew it he blew it yep we sorry
it was a Royal Rumble I think it was the
first or second year I was in WWF back
in a day and I was gonna be like the
number four guy left you know at the end
of the Royal Rumble I mean you're the
kind of starting to you know build me by
making me the number four guy that was
gonna be thrown out lasting and so all
of a sudden thought to junior
I can remember you know everybody's
wondering baby all and so basically he's
gonna clothesline me over the top
I'm just gonna you know basically land
on apron come back in hail he hit me so
hard with that damn clothesline it was
zip zip zip I'm on the damn floor the
San Diego sports sports arena and I was
an integral part of the end of the thing
because Shawn Michaels was involved and
there I am laying on the floor outside
of the ring I had F the maximum degree
you can and all of a sudden you're not
like well I gotta give Shawn the Iggy
that you know I've been eliminated and
I'm not supposed to be eliminated for
quite some time here so I'm looking over
the hey I'm out of here
and Shawn's eyes while he's getting [ __ ]
beat up in the middle ring like there
was my opportunity and I was like hot
dog but I was like man they're giving
you an opportunity you just completely
effed it up we need to be fair though
you had a big Samoan man throwing you
throwing his body weight into you
knocking you over the top rope hot dog
he couldn't have had a smoother landing
and he still [ __ ] yeah we said go ahead
ask don't call the questions right here
you've got nice in your in your age
don't like I'm trying to be the Dalai
Lama is that his name yeah by the way
I'd like a goodwill ambassador right I'm
trying to climb I'm trying to watch the
language now you can curse it's okay
well beat it up okay are you are you big
DME chief Jay Strongbow yeah when I
first came into and this goes back to
when it was still F chief Jay Strongbow
was cool man because he was one of the
guys along with Brisco slaughter
blackjack lands took me under his wing
George animal Steele had a lot of great
advice for me and Jay was super
old-school and it was all about saving
your money and you too yeah he was very
instrumental and given me a lot of
advice it probably is weird what a lot
of those guys was talking about two
things that you would never expect rest
of the money and investing and all this
stuff that guys just you wouldn't think
that they would talk to you way back in
a day when you can still buy a house for
a relatively small amount of money back
in their territory days because you
never knew how long you can last in the
territory
most of the boy is way back in the day
and again houses were a way more cost
efficient than they are these days but
you always bought a house if you bought
a house
she bought it in cash you bought it in
cash because no one could take it from
you didn't have to make any payments on
it right and that was your security
blanket if you got hurt if a promotion
shit-canned you that was the one thing
that you had and so that was just a
mentality from from the boys way back in
the day now and you learn that from
chief Jay
well that was yeah chief Jay and a lot
of guys did that and then I'm gonna
never forget riding on an airplane one
time and Terry Taylor had his tray up in
front of him it's probably the early 90s
and he's got receipts everywhere and I
said Jay I said what are you doing he
goes I'm just writing down all my
receipts all my cost and everything like
that for my taxes so you know he was
kind of ahead of ahead of the curve as
far as you know keeping track of all of
his expenses you know I had a fanny pack
hell of so much is fold about a pound
worth of paper yeah and all the other
[ __ ] that we carried most of which
is illegal these guys you know took care
of the the business aspect of it while
he had some downtime on an airplane
right I was usually drinking you know
Bloody Marys and whatever having a good
time yeah I'm making a time you took a
break from podcasting you were running
some repeats on the old Steve Austin
show which is back you've had what Hulk
Hogan
Mark Henry D no you haven't done who'd
you have from aw Tony Kanaan that's the
one but you took like a six-month hiatus
where they were running repeats what
happened man I just needed to break you
know I've had several things to go on
and I'd kind of just hit hit the ceiling
or hit the wall and I needed a just a
break to kill my brain out and half time
man I love people and I want to give you
a hug right now by the same token man I
can be pretty antisocial when I used to
go to the ranch man I shut the gates if
I didn't see another human being for two
months man I'm good so anyway I just
kind of hit the wall there for a little
bit needed a little bit of a break kind
of a reset and recharge the batteries
and I'm getting all these emails I mean
like emails with some hate some tone and
I'm like hey man I [ __ ] low you go
take a break yeah it was like his weird
so I mean I was happy that people wanted
me back on
err as much as they did yeah so anyway
after a break and I I wanted to come
back because the thing I love about the
podcasts and the reason I started the
podcast uh I had wanted to start one
about a year before I did but I don't
know anything about technology how to
get the started or do whatever and some
agents call me and they said hey man we
just got a phone call from podcast one
do you want to do a podcast I said you
damn right I do so we wouldn't took the
meeting and I said it started up and Sam
the thing about that was you know when
you leave WWE you know that's a huge
platform to you know promote anything
the core have so I mean hell I might as
I'll be out there on the corner of
Lincoln and Washington there in Marina
del Rey with the damn bullhorn hey I got
a CD for sale or whatever you know you
don't have that voice anymore so even
though my podcast is at a much smaller
level
I mean much you know then what the W
platform is it is a voice for me to stay
in direct contact you know to stay in
contact with all the fans that it took
me you know through all the years of
wrestling to build up and a direct line
of communication and they helped promote
a lot podcasters oh yeah because it's a
targeted thing people who are listening
really want to listen and they actually
do better than a lot of radio shows
podcasts are great for promotion and
then I added nothing by the way by
saying no but on that point you know
what I say about something I mean it'll
get it'll get picked up and it'll make
the wire so I mean oh yeah you don't
have to just listen to my podcast you
can you can you can be reading the
internet and something that stone cold
or Steve Austin said on his podcast is
gonna get traction so it just it keeps
my presence there to help me push you
know all the things that I'm doing do
you feel like you're gonna do that kind
of cycle where you do it for six months
so take six months off you'll go back
and forth it's fine you keep doing it
purely needed a break and and now the
thing is it was so hard because you know
during many of those years I would go
into production whether it was you know
redneck island down in Mexico and I've
got no material or where there's broken
skull challenge I'm working you know
14-hour days before you know podcast you
know you've got to do some research yeah
what might be an hour or an hour and a
half show you you might have put six
eight ten twelve whatever
kind of prep you put into that show you
ain't got time to do that when you're in
production you're working your ass off
so that was that was you know one of the
things that kind of led to needy needing
a break but I'll continue the podcast
for quite some time do you think you'd
be keeping up with wrestling if not for
the podcast because you talked about the
current product all the time but do you
think you'd be watching it on that level
if you weren't doing the podcast yeah
yeah because man I love the business and
I DVR all the shows and then if someone
says hey man check us out because this
was a cool angle or someone comes along
with a lot of potential then I'll kind
of see where they're at or what people
are saying about them are seeing in them
and see if I see those same things so I
would still stay in touch with the
business because I don't know if the
sounds uh when I came up and I couldn't
be you know a rock and roll star you
know being a professional wrestler was
my lifelong dream and I had to ride off
in the sunset after give or take about
13 years and you know gone for a year
with the neck injury gone for six or
eight months cuz I basically said hey go
F yourself when they wanted me to job
out for a Brock Lesnar which I would've
been happy to do the job you know had it
been a built match in the right time
right bad timing so I wasn't in the
business that long when you really think
about it but that's what that's that's
one of the my biggest passions in life
is professional wrestling what do you
think Kevin Owens stunner he's doing the
Kevin Owens as a restaurant Smackdown
he's doing the stunner which is Stone
Cold's finisher as his finisher he says
for the audience not for you he's coming
around a little bit different approach
than I got but I mean he's coming around
and I'm glad he's using it because I
like Kevin Owens and it's funny
many years ago I can't remember it I
think it was in Toronto or some area of
some airport somewhere and he just came
up to me and introduced himself to me
I'd never heard of him because I am
Kevin Steen and I'm trying to get in
business why I am a wrestler and I do
you have any advice for me and he tells
a story I said yeah man I said you need
to learn you need to learn how to cut a
promo I said learn how to learn how to
run your mouth kid easy for me to say
well he took it to heart oh yeah now
he's like a an a-plus promo yeah he told
me said that you said never stop talking
and that's why everyone
he's in the ring mid-match like he just
talks non-stop but back in the day he
had all these crazy moves it is doing
nothing man only moves you can only do
those you know for so for so long but
you can run your mouth forever long as
you have a base you know you need your
offense you need to move set you need to
be able to work he can as well as anyone
but you've got to have that character to
make people believe in you or have
something to love or hate about you and
then back it up to sell tickets with
words well that's the lesson isn't it
that I mean if anybody can prove that
you can run your mouth forever
it's Stone Cold Steve Austin he's still
running his mouth a podcast guy TV show
but when you go back and look at my move
[ __ ] I mean [ __ ] what I did now I mean
people off I had a stop at a corner and
a big right hand and that was about it
yeah I lose that's press everything I
was drinking for 11:00 and resting on
the side it all worked
did anybody get pissed that you said
[ __ ] on Raw I didn't care if they did or
not that was an organic [ __ ] yeah
Organic [ __ ]
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM Adam